this is the USS Louisiana it's one of
the Navy's current 14 nuclear-powered
ballistic missile submarines
this is China's version the type 094
it's one of the nation's six
nuclear-powered ballistic missile
submarines
these submarines serve the same purpose
they're a sort of insurance policy in
the event of a nuclear attack
but to do its job each of these
submarines has to do one thing really
well hide
We compare the Ohio class submarines
technical capabilities and missiles with
the Gin classes to see which comes out
on top and take a look at what each
country has in store for the future of
these nuclear-powered ballistic missile
submarines
on June 9 1959 a decade into the Cold
War the United States launched this
submarine the USS George Washington it
was the Navy's first nuclear-powered
ballistic missile submarine these ssbns
are nuclear-powered carry nuclear
missiles and are one arm of the U.S
military's nuclear Triad which includes
intercontinental ballistic missiles
ballistic missile submarines and bombers
and for the United States ssbns became a
crucial part of its nuclear Triad
because of their survivability that is
their ability to remain safe from
anti-submarine Warfare and if needed
launch missiles past enemy defenses
in fact ssbns are the most survivable
arm in the Triad
so in the 1980s the first ohio-class
nuclear-powered ballistic missile
submarine entered service
the Ohio class still active today was
the Navy's sixth generation of ssbns 18
submarines in this class were built over
the next 16 years though four were later
converted into cruise missile submarines
as these Ohio class ssbns were procured
China was building its first ballistic
missile submarine the type-092 which
became operational in 1983. they only
fielded one but it marked a turning
point in China's nuclear capabilities
a few decades later in 2006 satellite
imagery spotted the Next Generation the
type 094 in its 2022 annual report the
Department of Defense says China has six
operational gin-class submarines running
deterrence Patrols
but these type 094s are much noisier
than the 1970s era Soviet nuclear
submarines and that's where the
significantly undermined the overall
survivability of the Chinese submarines
and therefore undermines the overall
credibility of its sea-based nuclear
deterrence Dr
abilities and strategy
for about a decade
the ohio-class submarines are capable of
carrying up to 24 missiles but to comply
with the new start treaty only 20 are
allowed to be carried in contrast the
gin-class submarines can only carry up
to 12 missiles
and like each submarine's survivability
the missiles they carry are also
critical factors in each military's
strategy the Navy's ssbns have held a
variety of missiles today the Ohio class
submarines carried this missile the
Trident II
it's 44 feet long has an 83 inch
diameter and weighs a hundred and thirty
thousand pounds that's about the weight
of five school buses
although the Trident II can carry up to
eight Warheads it likely carries only
three or four to comply with the new
start treaty
but most importantly it has a range of
about 4 000 nautical miles and since
2017 the Navy has been updating these
missiles to extend their life and
increase their range even more to about
6480 nautical miles
the Department of Defense says that
China's gin-class submarines carry
either the jl2 or its next iteration the
jl3
the jl2 has one Warhead while the jl3
has multiple
the jl2's range is estimated to be about
3780 nautical miles and the jl3s range
reaches at least 5 400 nautical miles
this means that from China's Shores the
jl2 has sufficient range to Target Guam
or Alaska but the jl3 might Target the
continental U.S from areas near China's
Coast but even if you put a longer range
missiles on the gym class submarines
it's still the gym class submarine there
still is no exists the old ones Hans
Christensen has studied the status of
American nuclear weapons since the 1980s
and since noisiness impacts an ssbn's
survivability it makes it harder for
China's submarines to travel further
from the shores without being detected
even if you get longer range that range
is not sufficient to cover all of the
continental United States unless you
sail far into the Pacific and that's
also difficult for China's submarines to
do because of U.S anti-submarine
defenses across the Pacific Ocean a sea
based nuclear capabilities is one area
in which China still lacks behind the
United States in a very significant
manner China understands that eventually
nuclear submarine may be the most
survivable part of our country's nuclear
Arsenal so China had this long-term
Vision to eventually acquire a very
Advanced nuclear submarine Technologies
so what's China working on to close the
gap
China is expected to begin construction
on its next generation of ssbn the type
096 in the first part of this decade
these submarines will run with the
existing gen class ones and experts like
Dr Zhao say that the type 096 will be
quieter than its predecessor
but the US is forging ahead too
construction on the next generation of
ssbns is already underway these Columbia
class Boomers will be even bigger than
their predecessors
this thing about the modernization cycle
you know they don't happen at the same
time in China and the United States so
they're sometimes sort of a simplistic
tendency or a Temptation in the debate
for nuclear Advocates to say see they're
modernizing we're not therefore we're
behind but now we have actually now
we're entering our modernization cycle
um
and that will run for the next two to
three decades the Ohio class submarines
are reaching the end of their lifetime
in just a few years the first of its
generation the USS Ohio will retire
by 2040 they are said to be replaced by
Columbia class ssbns the Navy is
acquiring 12 new ssbns and each one will
have room for 16 missiles eight less
than the Ohio class could carry cutting
back might seem counter-intuitive but
the U.S military estimates no more are
needed to meet nuclear deterrence
requirements and the U.S Navy says the
columbia-class submarines will be even
quieter that's because they're being
built with an electric Drive propulsion
train versus the traditional mechanical
drive system so even if China's type 096
is considerably quieter than its
predecessor it could be far less
stealthy than the US's upcoming Columbia
class so we may see some incremental
improvements that doesn't mean that
China will be at the same technical
level with this American counterpunch
[Music]
foreign